hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the budapest
queen trap
and it is a good one so the budapest
starts out with
d4 knight f6 c4 and then
pawn to e5 this is not the most sound
defense by any means so if you are going
to play the budapest
why not play a super fun traps after the
pawn takes here on e5
usually black plays knight to g4
gets the knight out of harm's way also
attacks the pawn here on e5
but second best move is to play knight
to e4
a very fun variation as well they're
usually not gonna kick it away with
pawn two f3 their d-pawn is already
moved so they're not going to be
attacking this knight with that
and so how do they continue well knight
to f3 is pretty common to protect this
pawn here on e5 they're
up in material you want to protect the
center of the board this makes a lot of
sense and this is where we start to lay
the trap it starts with pawn
two b6 now this move is just asking our
opponent
and it is the correct move for white to
play queen to
d5 this is attacking the knight here on
e4
attacking the rook on a8 and it kind of
looks like what in the world is black
doing do they even know understand how
opening chess theory works like they're
just giving up tons of material
little do they know that we have a trap
for them we are going to play bishop to
b7 yes the bishop is unprotected
yes we want them to take our bishop so
after the queen takes here on
b7 then we're going to play knight to
c6 if you're watching the video and you
recognize
black is not taking in material yet that
is okay
because we're looking to take the queen
here on b7
now the immediate threat that white has
to worry about is black playing
knight to c5 attacking the queen
the knight here on c5 is attacking the
a6 square which would be the only safe
square that white could go to
right away and so white could decide
okay i need to start getting my queen to
safety here
let's start with the move queen to a6
but this does not solve
white's issues and in fact this is
actually losing
for whites because black can play the
move bishop
here to b4 now we'll look at two
variations they could play you know
knight two
c3 they could also play bishop here to
d2 we'll look at both of those options
uh they both lead to white's demise here
but we'll first look at knight 2
c3 well doesn't matter we're going to
play knight 2
c5 attacking the queen queen comes back
to b5
and then just to move pawn to a6 now
white has no moves they are going to
lose their queen so let's say queen
takes here on b4
knight takes here on b4 and black should
have an easy game from here and also
black still has more threats knight to
c2 check forking the rook here on
a one now slight variation in if they
play
bishop to d2 uh you do need to change it
up a little bit after you played knight
two
c5 and they play queen two b5 uh you
need to go ahead and take first
so after they take with their knights
here you can just play pawn
to a6 and now their queen is going to
fall and the reason for that is
if you don't if you just play pawn to
a6 first well now they can take with
their queen here on
b4 take our bishop and yes we do take
their queen
but then they take with their bishop and
you can see black has given up
three minor pieces and a pawn
for the queen compared to if you just
look at
normal when they played knight to c3
here and we played knight to c5
and then all of a sudden we play a6 and
we take their
queen you can see we've only given up
two minor pieces in a pawn for the queen
so very different
uh much better situation so just make
sure if they play their bishop you do
take
the bishop first check so they have to
respond to it and then you play that
pawn to
a6 okay so we've seen from white
standpoint that queen to a6
is not going to go well for them so what
other options do they have one of them
is going to be
bishop to e3 since they know the threat
is knight to c5 they could just play
bishop to e3 and say yeah i'm just going
to attack
that square right away but
very difficult for white to actually
continue i think in this spot
after bishop to b4 check now
a few options we'll go through each of
those we have knight to c3 here
probably the best variation for them
they could play knight to d2
they could also just bring the bishop
back here to d2 probably the worst of
the options and we'll go through each
one so knight 2
c3 here knight takes on
c3 and you can see this gets
pretty rough here because if pawn takes
on c3 which looks logical well bishop
takes on c3
check for king the rook so bishop to d2
and then the bishop takes here on a1 so
that's
that's not going to go extremely well so
how do they really
continue from here well they can't take
so maybe they play bishop back here to
d2 it's just not
a very easy situation for them at
all now if instead of playing knight two
c3 maybe they played knight to
d2 okay well now we're just going to
take with our knights and they have two
options they could take with their
knight they could take
with their bishop if they take with
their knights well we're just going to
play pawn to
a5 and they can't really stop the move
rook to
a7 on the next move and then the queen
is going to
fall if they don't take with their
knight let's say if they take with their
bishop here
then we're going to go ahead and take
with our bishop after the knight
plays then pawn to a6 similar to pawn to
a5 we're looking to play rook to a7 and
they're going to lose their
queen now uh if you kind of run this
through an engine they might tell you
that the best move is
queen or castle on the queen side it is
extremely difficult if you're in this
situation from white to look at this and
say you know what
i'm gonna castle on the queen side all
the safety is completely gone
this knight on here d2 is solidified by
the bishop
i'm going to castle on the queen side
then allow my opponent to play knight
takes on c4 gobble up more pawns
this seems highly unlikely that white's
going to actual castle on the queen side
and then play it effectively from then
on out so it is
i think it's very difficult if someone's
going to play bishop to
e3 to try to defend that and then the
last option
which is probably the best option but is
to play knight
to d4 now the knight on
d4 is attacking it from a different
situation where
white recognizes that after the knight
takes here on
c6 and then the pawn captures then the
queen could take here on
c6 and that would not only escape the
queen but it would also
check the king here on e8 but i still
think there's a lot of threats that
white has to deal with
after knight two d4 which is the best
move that white has
because after bishop here to b4
how do they continue that they should
continue with knight to c3 black can
always hope for the best case scenario
and that is to play king to
d1 white should absolutely not do this
this would be a terrible move this would
actually be made in two
if you if you were to run a uh run
into this in real life uh please
screenshot and send to me because it
would just be amazing you can play
knight takes on f2
they have to play king to c2
then you play knight takes on d4 and
this would be a checkmate
probably not going to do that instead
you might see knight two c3
uh from here though we take with our
knight here on
c3 and they're still in a pretty tough
spot here because if they take with
their pawn
we take bishop c3 check and then we take
their rook here on a one with a fork
okay so that's not the best option if
they try something else maybe they say
let's play pawn to a3 kicking the bishop
away uh because you know this knight's
gonna move it's gonna be a discovered
attack on the king here
but we'll just go ahead and take that
bishop that's fine though because we
could play
knight two b5 check discovered attack as
as we we thought yes sure okay now the
pawn takes
we take this knight here on d4 but we're
also
threatening to move knight to c2 check
so
they're going to have to deal with that
maybe king 2 d1 rook to b8 attacking the
queen here queen comes here to
a6 and then we have the creative move
knight to
c2 and they can't really take it because
then they lose their queen
knight takes here on b4 forking the
queen here
but even if they don't take the next
move from black is the play
knight takes here on b4 all of a sudden
white's king is exposed we're have a lot
of threats with our knights here
we can get our queen involved into the
game so i think this is a pretty tough
spot
for white now really the best move that
they have
here is going to play knight takes on
c6 the main reason you played knight to
d4 is to take here on
c6 but they still run into threats
because after pawn
to c6 black is threatening the move
queen to d1 checkmate so
white has to be extremely careful with
how they're going
to continue they can't just play you
know pawn to a3 because then they lose
the game so they have to be thinking
about that really the best move for them
is to play bishop here to
d2
after bishop to d2 black can do last
ditch effort of
knight takes here on a2
uh remember we still have the threat
with our
queen right here so that they can't just
take they would
lose the game here on uh d2
but instead they could say you know
bishop takes here on b4
okay knight takes here and black doesn't
have a terrible game now the the optimal
move for
for white in this position just to play
rook to
d1 you do want to protect this d file uh
and this does exactly that but you still
have the queen here on b7 you got to get
that out of harm's way
uh so you black uh still has some
threats but white if they play optimum
which you can see there's a lot of
tricky moves that white would have to
come up with
uh to not lose this game so i think this
is a pretty fun opening
and trap that especially for black like
if you have
this down and you know every situation
inside it out it's gonna be very
difficult for your opponent to navigate
this correctly
and you can just obliterate some people
with this so hopefully you guys enjoyed
the budapest queen trap if you actually
uh deploy this and it works on your
opponent
let me know i'd love to see the game
send it to me
let me know in the chat as well i think
it is a good one so hopefully you
enjoyed this
video and i will see you guys next time